if you are embarking on a plant-based
diet for the first time there's a few
things that can really help with the
success of that so one thing you can do
is okay I like if I like having chicken
tacos I'm gonna do maybe chickpea tacos
you're still developing recipes that are
like what you're used to eating and then
you will find by rotating through these
recipes oh I like that I can cook that
my family like that number two get
support so sometimes you can feel like
you're on a lonely Furrow going
plant-based so find a body you know in
your neighborhood a friend a cousin
someone you say hey I'm doing this
plant-based challenge for 30 days can
you join me because then it becomes fun
and now you're sharing recipes and
you're bringing potlucks over to each
other's homes and it becomes a joyous
thing it shouldn't be about deprivation